bien bonjour à toutes et à tous et merci
à monsieur le ministre d'être venu
nouvelle fois au sénat puisque le
remarquent tout à l'heure il vient
souvent au sénat et c'est vrai que après
une phase de concertation
la réforme ferroviaire est maintenant
rentrer dans la phase parlementaire et
je dirais même dans l'actualité la
commission de l'union durable de
l'assemblée nationale s'est prononcé la
semaine dernière nos collègues députés
donc examineront le projet de loi en
séance publique la semaine prochaine
et de notre côté nous l'examinerons donc
en commission le mercredi 25 juin
prochain et en sciences début juillet il
est bon donc que nous puissions aborder
dans le détail donc cette réforme dit
pourquoi vous souhaitons vous entendre
monsieur le ministre mais sur cette
audition intervient dans un contexte
social un peu particulier dans tout le
monde dit que vous avez la clé la clé de
de pouvoir en quelque sorte remettre les
choses dans le bon sens mais c'est vrai
que c'est important de savoir un petit
peu sur ce sujet si vous pouvez nous
dire quelques mots de la manière dont
pourrait s'arrêter ce conflit qui
évidemment tombe très mal monsieur
michel teston bien sûr notre rapporteur
vous interrogera le premier
et puis après votre intervention et puis
s'ils le souhaitent et s'il a le temps
mais pas le cas président françois
patriat qui est ici au titre de son
rapport de la commission des finances
veut fera également beaucoup de sujets
intéressent nos collègues en particulier
sur le problème de la dette que nous
avons longuement abordé au cours des
deux auditions précédentes nous avons
donc auditionné monsieur guillaume pepy
jacques rapoport ce matin et bien sûr
ces sujets ont été abordés mais nous
espérons aussi qu'on pourrait nous
donner quelques informations
un autre sujet important la place des
régions dans ce dispositif avait deux et
deux éléments d'actualité comment va
s'articuler ce texte est celui de la
réforme territoriale notamment la
refonte des cartes des régions où en
est-on de l'avancement des volets de
mobilité dans les futurs contrats de
projets etat-régions bien sûr sont des
sujets d'actualité sur lesquels beaucoup
s'interrogent enfin toujours en matière
d'aménagement de territoire
telle est la position du gouvernement
sur le maintien et la réhabilitation des
lignes secondaires qui contribuera au
désenclavement des territoires tout
court et les territoires ruraux et
comment développer la mobilité d'une
manière plus durable voilà donc les
quelques questions que nous avons
recueillies discuter et bien sûr nous
attendons monsieur le ministre vous
puissiez nous en parler avec la
franchise est hélas compétentes dont
vous avez toujours fait preuve quand
même venu ici au sénat voilà monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole vous avez
une bonne demi heure
si vous ne voulez plus si vous avez
besoin
je pense qu'on est tous très conscients
de l'importance de ceux du bas cette
réforme
ce matin des mots très forts ont été
employés donc celle ci ce président sera
porteur mesdames messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs
merci pour votre indulgence d'abord et
pour les propos agréable entend surtout
lorsqu'on est en charge des transports
et que l'actualité est quotidienne et
souvent l'actualité sociale peut être un
mot sur cette actualité pour faire le
point de ce que les inquiétudes elles
sont exprimés sous des formes
différentes certain nombre
d'organisations ont décidé d'engager une
grève reconductible
d'autres au contraire ont souhaité
poursuivre le dialogue qu'il veut pas
dire d'ailleurs que lorsqu'on est en
grève
il n'y a pas de dialogue loin s'en faut
mais sous des formes différentes et j'ai
indiqué que nous mêmes que nous sommes
en contact depuis plus d'un an et demi
avec l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales
nous serions alors disposition dès ce
soir j'ai anticipé j'avais donné rendez
vous aux organisations syndicales avant
même que ce préavis de grève ne soit
lancé et exercer mais j'ai anticipé
autant que de besoin
cette rencontre qui sera ce soir un tour
d'horizon de la situation et qui se
poursuivra demain demain matin demain
après midi
peut-être au-delà si c'est nécessaire en
tout cas je me rendrai plus largement
disponibles pour pouvoir relever les
défis et c'est important de
l'explication de ce projet de loi
maintenant le parlement et votent aulas
autre assemblée également saisi sera
appelée faire évoluer ce texte ce que
j'ai d'ailleurs indiqué aux
organisations syndicales la procédure
législative elle est aussi là pour
enrichir amendé par nature et améliorer
autant que de besoin donc je n'ai pas là
de deux soucis de susceptibilité
d'auteur
au contraire je pense que l'aco
rédaction surtout lorsqu'elle est
parlementaire est nécessaire pour
pouvoir avoir un texte qui soit le plus
opérationnel sur des orientations qui
sont des orientations visant à renforcer
le service public et de peut-être
préciser parce que j'ai entendu beaucoup
de choses des reportages sur les lieux
de grève qu'il n'ya pas pour lui il n'y
a pas pour objet dans ce texte de
privatisation de libéralisation c'est un
sujet à débat voire même un combat qui
se mène ailleurs je ferai le point dans
quelques secondes de 7,2 ce contexte
européen
après vous que le gouvernement avait dès
ses premiers jours indiqué qu'il
n'anticipait pas la libéralisation telle
que voulue par l'europe et que dans la
discussion du quatrième paquet
ferroviaire j'y reviendrai au contraire
nous souhaiterions et nous souhaitions
et nous souhaitons faire en sorte que la
voix de la france soit portée aux sur la
spécificité de l'organisation
ferroviaire je reviendrai donc c'est un
premier point et d'autre part la
question des statuts dont on dit qu'elle
serait indirectement contenues dans ce
texte non ce qui est une réalité
c'est prenant exemple et appuyez sur une
expérience malheureuse de libéralisation
mal préparé du fret qui ne traitait pas
la question des conditions salariales
nous avions et nous avons aujourd'hui un
fret ferroviaire qui est malgré tout
malgré la présence d'une vingtaine
d'opérateurs différents avec des statuts
totalement différent eux mêmes avec des
règles qu'il ne sent pas harmonisés et
surtout avec des conditions de dialogue
social qui ne peuvent pas s'exprimer
de sorte que ce que nous souhaitons et
nous leur envoyons après au dialogue au
dialogue social à la discussion
c'est qu'il il existe qui se met en
place devant la multiplicité des
opérateurs ferroviaires et ça que ce
augmenté qu'il y ait une convention
collective applicable à l'ensemble de
l'activité ferroviaire c'est
indispensable sinon il ya distorsion
signons il ya une concurrence qui sera
effective là au moment où elle
s'imposera mais elle doit être une
concurrence sur des bases claires et non
pas génératrice d'une forme de dumping y
compris dans le ferroviaire je me base
suffisamment dans le transport routier
dans le transport maritime et vous en
êtes les témoins et même les acteurs par
les textes que nous votons pour essayer
de faire en sorte que nous puissions
avoir des règles harmonisées des règles
tirant vers le haut et qui évite des
formes de concurrence déloyale d'un
point de vue social donc un statut
social harmonisé et bien il en va de
même pour le ferroviaire or cette
question n'a pas été traité et il est
urgent de le traiter avant même que de
nouveaux acteurs ferroviaires ne vienne
intervenir dans le cadre d'une
libéralisation futur qui ne sera je le
répète pas anticiper et qui nous impose
en revanche l'impérieuse nécessité de
préparer notre service public notre
établissement public aux enjeux de cette
réalité de ce cadre qui sera évolutif
alors j'ai parlé très rapidement du
quatrième paquet peut-être ferroviaire
peut-être puis je donner d'entrée le jeu
cette dimension européenne vous souvenez
d'ailleurs ici même un certain nombre de
questions avaient été posées il ya deux
ans sur la compatibilité de notre projet
de loi qui n'était que mon premier
esprit c'est les premières rédaction et
notamment sur le fait que nous aurions
nous serions rattraperait rattrapé par
le quatrième paquet ferroviaire et que
celui ci nous imposerait un modèle
d'organisation il n'en est rien et je
l'avais d'ailleurs indiqué
devant votre commission qu'il était
important que nous puissions obtenir de
la part de l'europe une forme de
reconnaissance du principe de
subsidiarité quand l'organisation même
des systèmes ferroviaires c'est vrai
pour la france c'est vrai d'autres pays
et cette position a été rejoint par un
certain nombre d'acteurs européens qui
tire en conséquence d'une de ce qu'est
le ferroviaire
une évolution une construction de l'état
même du domaine du patrimoine de l'état
il fallait que nous puissions avoir une
europe du transport et particulièrement
du ferroviaire qui permettent d'avoir
des réseaux vras la dimension européenne
et que nous puissions être efficace sur
cette interopérabilité nécessaires sur
des frontières souvent techniques ou de
réglementations qui doivent tomber mais
que l'organisation n'était pas celle qui
devait être commandée par une forme de
pensée unique qui est la pensée unique
du commissaire kallas simca naslund
building cher à son dogme qui serait la
séparation absolue étanche un peu
anticipé en 97 par la loi de 97 et on en
voit les conséquences nous avons aussi
discuté beaucoup au niveau européen je
le dis parce que le paquet politique
quatrième paquet ferroviaire que l'on
magitek hommes comme d'épouvantail non
seulement n'a pas été voté sur la
gouvernance pas encore et pas avant à
mon sens 2015 mais en plus et donc
l'intérêt est grand de pouvoir avoir
nous mêmes une législation qui
influencent et qui pèsent sur
l'organisation européenne de demain est
par ailleurs la question du financement
par les gestionnaires d'infrastructures
ou au profit des gestionnaires
d'infrastructures était une une question
extrêmement importante et je crois
pouvoir dire mais j'aurai l'occasion
d'être plus précis lors des débats que
le modèle que nous
nous devons mettre en place permet de
d'assurer une forme de contribution au
financement des infrastructures par le
transporteur et en l'occurrence à sa
mobilité au même titre que d'autres
permettant ainsi de réduire le fardeau
de la dette c'est un enjeu qui était un
enjeu indispensable parce que l'europe
dans un premier temps souhaité au
contraire que l'on coupe les liens
capitalistiques ou financiers entre les
différentes entités
mais dans le sens du soutien à
l'infrastructure contrairement à
d'autres pays qui au contraire par
l'infrastructure financent eux le
transporteur
nous avons de ce point de vue je crois
pleine reconnaissance de leur
compatibilité de cette logique qui est
une logique de préservation du bien
commun du patrimoine commun c'est-à-dire
l'infrastructure trop souvent trop
longtemps négligé doit être la priorité
y compris dans les modes de financement
voilà pourquoi
cette question et sept combats cette
discussion au niveau européen était
extrêmement élevé encore sensible et
qu'il fallait mener de front cet enjeu
parce que nous ne pouvions pas ne pas
compter comme ça je suis trop longtemps
le cas sur la spécificité ferroviaire ne
pas porter notre conception même de la
réalité du service public des
obligations de service public
j'ai encore dit à mon homologue monsieur
lupi nous lors du dernier ministre
italien des transports et qui va sur à
la présidence pour les six prochains
mois que l'on ne pouvait aborder la
question de la gouvernance et donc d'une
forme de libéralisation dans le
calendrier sand en même temps et
préalablement que l'on définisse les
obligations de service public
parce que dans ce cas vous auriez des
attributions et nous savons combien
lorsqu'il n'ya pas de cadre préétabli
répondant à ceux qui se trouvent être
des enjeux d'aménagement du territoire
dgt équilibre des investissements nous
aurions alors des formes de
privatisation de libéralisation sur des
lignes rentables et au contraire une
nationalisation au sens large avec les
collectivités avec l'état sur des lignes
qui sautent des lignes qui n'ont pas le
trafic suffisant pour être rentable donc
le cadre de l'obligation service public
est extrêmement important c'est vrai que
nous ne sommes pas nombreux au niveau
européen à défendre cette conception
mais lorsque la france
et lorsqu'elle est soutenu et respecté
par ses partenaires pose le problème de
2,7 de nécessité de reconnaissance de la
spécificité même du service public de
cet enjeu d'intérêt général alors elle
est écoutée mérite écoute et à condition
qu'elle ne plaide pas en interne une
séparation je rencontrais mon
prédécesseur à l'instant questions
d'actualité à l'assemblée nationale
lundi quand combien sa vision
séparatiste avait fait du mal non
seulement par les dysfonctionnements
parce que c'est là au delà de l'enjeu
européen ce qui nous préoccupe de
pouvoir assurer ce qui est une attente
des cheminots mais c'est une attente a
prioritairement des usagers des
collectivités des régions qui financent
largement le ferroviaire que ce
séparatisme avait amené des
dysfonctionnements et il n'est jamais
jamais une mauvaise chose que de
reconnaître des erreurs ou des voix qui
n'a mené pas vers la réussite
aujourd'hui ce qui est attendu c'est du
confort c'est de la régularité c'est de
l'entretien des voies
c'est une stratégie est précisément ce
que nous souhaitons c'est que nous
puissions organiser une véritable erreur
aussi ce débat là qui est légitime
représentant de la nation que sont les
parlementaires que nous puissions avoir
une stratégie définie pour la nation une
stratégie du ferroviaire avec
régulièrement eu un rendu d'étape et
d'un contrôle ce pourquoi l'état qui
était absent considérant que la
politique ferroviaire devait être opérés
par la seule sncf elle même séparés dans
ses fonctions eh bien nous avons
souhaité remettre la légitimité au
niveau du parlement par la nécessité de
présenter l'orientation de la politique
ferroviaire
et puis par la composition des organes
directeurs j'y reviendrai dans quelques
instants
présence de l'état réaffirmé n'est qu'un
tiers du conseil d'administration actuel
de
la sncf n'est pas suffisant elle doit
être majoritaire c'est l'état des
régions qui aujourd'hui réclament
légitimement un certain nombre de
reconnaissance et de transparence dans
la façon dont les choses se sont réglées
et il est vrai que dans leur évolution y
compris des de la décentralisation et de
la carte territoriale il faut que les
régions puissent puisqu'elles financent
déjà
et puisque la clarification des
compétences viendra à leur transmettre
ne part plus importante de la compétence
sur les transports et bien qu'elle soit
aussi des acteurs de ce grand défi de la
modernisation du transport ferroviaire
alors nous devons améliorer la qualité
du service public
nous verrons devons maîtriser également
sa trajectoire financière nous devons
aborder la question du cadre social ou
en tout cas les grandes règles
permettant d'assurer les lieux et moyen
du dialogue social et il faut pour cela
que nous puissions avoir un système qui
ne soit pas handicapé par la gouvernance
le handicap de la gouvernance est
d'avoir des missions qui sont des
missions éclaté alors même qu'elles
doivent être rassemblés et ses missions
je pense l'infrastructure qui
aujourd'hui se trouve être une
organisation assez étrange tellement
étrange que y compris les gens du
ferroviaire c'est qu'on ne s'y retrouve
plus entre la dcf entre la sncf infra
qui eux-mêmes interviennent à la demande
des réflexes laquelle rff représente
1500 agents sur cent cinquante mille
agents de la famille cheminote c'est
dire combien il nous faut simplifier
tout simplement et faire que nous
puissions avoir un secteur public une
entreprise publique unifiée qui
elle-même clarifie les missions enfants
sains deux établissements publics qui
seront d'une part pour simplifier
beaucoup plus complexe et 600 filiale
sas et met deux grands corps de métier
l'infrastructure la gestion de
l'infrastructure et le la mobilité par
sncf mobilité bien sûr allez vous me
dire mais vous en sommes dans un
contexte où l'ouverture d'un certain
nombre de marchés de devra assurer des
règles du jeu qui soit des règles du jeu
transparence dans l'attribution des
sillons dans le respect des différents
intervenants
bref ce que l'on appelle les missions
essentielles la tarification et il est
évident que le régulateur aura sa
mission mais faut-il parce que certaines
fonctions dites essentielles peuvent
être exercés sans emprise de la part de
sncf mobilité éclater un système alors
même que nous avons besoin d'avoir des
personnes qui travaillent dans la même
direction dans le même sens avec la même
volonté là où pendant des années on leur
a appris à ne pas collaborer
elle ne pas se rencontrer et jouer de la
défiance
je souhaite donc renforcer le secteur
public avec vous donner à la nation les
moyens de définir sa stratégie
ferroviaire j'y faisais référence placé
l'état en état stratège avec des moyens
de financer et de piloter des acteurs
publics et mettre fin à l'enchevêtrement
des responsabilités c'est une nécessité
mais pour ça il faut et ce sera
peut-être la première fois depuis de
très longues années que nous aborderons
ce sujet il nous faut prendre à bras le
corps la question de la dette et des
réalités de cet endettement 40 milliards
aujourd'hui d'endettement car près de
deux milliards et demi à 3 milliards
d'accroissement automatique de la dette
101 travaux supplémentaires
accroissement automatique de la dette
qui vient bien évidemment vous verrez
toute forme de
d'efficacité de cette organisation peut
dire que si nous ne faisons rien c'est
une question de responsabilité je le
dirai ce soir aux organisations
syndicales
si nous ne faisons rien et je pourrais
être comme d'autres en considérant que
des successeurs parce qu'il son
successeur sont plus malins que soi même
et donc auront plus de compétences et de
capacité à apporter des réponses à des
sujets qui ne leur fait que croître et
non pas embellir pour le coup mais au
contraire se durcir dans la prise en
compte de la réalité
non il nous faut non pas transmettre aux
générations qui viennent par un manque
de courage politique
je sais que cette question est difficile
à aborder je sais combien il y a des
forces antagonistes et contradictoires
mais je sais aussi que si nous
n'assumons pas cela si nous n'essayons
pas de travailler tous ensemble
collectivité est un acteur du
ferroviaire organisations syndicales à
rétablir une perspective du secteur
ferroviaire alors nous d'abord
n'assumant pas leur responsabilité mais
aussi nous ne nous donnons pas de
perspectives d'avenir au ferroviaire
si nous ne faisons rien en disant ce
sont 80 milliards d'euros de déficit
certains disent mais il faut que l'état
prenne à son compte la dette mais je ne
ferait pas usage d'une éponge magique
qui pourrait automatiquement effacer
cette dette
d'abord parce que ce ne serait pas
vertueux est par ailleurs parce que je
n'en ai pas le pouvoir et que le
ministère des transports n'est pas
encore si tu es assez près de la scène
pour pouvoir prendre des décisions à
caractère ça compte aussi
mais en prenant en compte cette réalité
elle n'est pas masquer la réalité
politique il faut toujours l'intégrer
pour en faire plus tôt un atout que
inconvénients et faiblesses je me dis
que cette l'occasion pour nous de
démontrer que l'objectif est celui de la
stabilisation de la dette
si nous ne faisons pas des réformes de
structure madame la ministre j'ai
plaisir à saluer si nous ne faisons pas
ces réformes
si nous ne stabilisons pas la dette
alors il ne sera pas de bonne
administration de bons économie et de
bonne gestion que de demander à l'état
automatiquement d'intervenir sur des
dettes aussi importante
faisons la démonstration de l'efficacité
du secteur ferroviaire faisant les
réformes de structures nécessaires
donnons de la compétitivité que ce n'est
pas un gros mot
donnons de la compétitivité de la
productivité au secteur ferroviaire et
donnant lui les moyens de pouvoir
relever ce défi et surtout supprimer ce
fardeau
un certain nombre de dispositions sont
mises en oeuvre et j'y reviendrai en
répondant plus tôt à vos questions nous
avons donc la nécessité de répondre à
allonger plus large que l'opérateur
historique parce que je ne veux pas que
l'on considère que notre travail est
votre mission qui sera la mission
législative ne concerne qu'une réforme
de la sncf ou du groupe sncf
il s'agit bien de l'ensemble du
ferroviaire et lorsque je dis que la
nécessité pour nous et devant une
stratégie ferroviaire c'est précisément
parce que la stratégie ferroviaire elle
passe aussi par l'ensemble des acteurs
revue ferroviaire c'est dans ce sens que
le projet de loi crée un haut comité du
ferroviaire permettant aux parties
prenantes état région entreprises
ferroviaires usagers que l'on doit
entendre organisateurs organisations
syndicales de débattre des stratégies
nécessaires de la stratégie nationale du
l'ensemble du système ferroviaire et
puis je répondrais bien sûr à vos
questions sur le lien le lien de ceux à
l'intérieur de ce groupe public
ferroviaire fort contrôlée par l'état
par les personnes publiques
je le dis parce qu'on m'a dit j'entends
que le projet de loi serait l'éclatement
de la sncf en trois entités
il ya trois entités bien sûr qu'il y a
trois entités
il ya en tout cas deux entités sous une
entité qui est l'entité de la stratégie
de la réunification de la décision et du
pilotage du ferroviaire
vous avez un groupe un groupe c'est
plusieurs entités en effet mais qui sont
des entités relier ce sont des entités
qui sont non pas autonomes comme
certains souhaiteraient les avoir mais
au contraire rollier avec un lien fort
qui permettent de donner des directions
à l'organisation et de ce point de vue
je ferais je le dis et je compte sur les
amendements des parlementaires en sorte
que nous ayons un groupe je le dirai aux
organisations syndicales ce soit un
groupe qui puisse avoir des liens avec
ces établissements publics dont
lesquels dépendent du groupe de tête des
liens suffisamment serré pour que je ne
puisse pas revenir sur cette
organisation au bénéfice d'une
malheureuse alternance qui si elle
devait intervenir ce que ne fait on pas
aimé ne pas ce que j'avais si vous avez
la grève existe de façon massive aussi
c'est parce qu'il ya eu des voix qui se
sont élevées et qu'il y met lorsque nous
allons revenir
nous couperons le lien entre l'entité
mère et les deux entités fille eh bien
j'ai entendu ce message et cette
prévention et qui me renforce dans la
nécessité de renforcer ses liens
de sorte que il ne puisse y avoir ni
opérations de ciseaux ou de taille mais
au contraire qu'il y ait un groupe
public ferroviaire qui s'inscrivent dans
le temps et dans la stabilité
c'est indispensable donc de ce point de
vue merci de nous avoir prévenus des
parfois un songe
ce qui inquiète qui serait d'une
mauvaise gestion c'est cela par malheur
devait arriver et donc nous ferons tout
pour qu'il n'en soit pas ainsi je
reviendrai selon vos questions
l'organisation le directoire le
président de sncf mobilité et de sncf
infra au sein d'un directoire un conseil
d'administration les directeurs pardon
17 cfa franc et sincère mobilité qui
constitueront le directoire et puis un
président du conseil de surveillance qui
sera nommé par l'état et qui aura à non
seulement exécuté l'organisent les
orientations du conseil de surveillance
mais également en cas de désaccord de
trancher les questions stratégiques et
de donner là encore pleine mesure de
cette intégration
je puis vous parler mais je pense qu'il
est préférable que ce soit par sous la
forme de questions risquent d'être trop
trop longs et barbe hâtives mais à la
fois de ce que la raf aura comme mission
fixée par décret
en fin de mission qui seront prévues par
la loi et des des contrôles qui seront
exercés par barthel par ce régulateur
par lui donc notamment sur le ratio de
la dette sur la soutenabilité financière
du contrat entre l'état et la sncf
réseau bref un véritable rôle de
régulateur qui sera nécessaire de
conforter contrairement à ce que j'ai pu
lire ailleurs de ce projet de loi dont
la lancre n'était pas même sèche qu'il
était sur un certain nombre de
dispositions déjà mise en cause à tort
puisque l'antre si elle n'était pas
sèche n'était donc pas lisible ça n'est
précisément pas le sens d'un aux
régulateurs limitée régulateur contrarié
dans ses compétences mais bien d'un
régulateur qui assume la pertinence de
l'ensemble de l'organisation on parlera
également des questions sociales sur la
nécessité de créer les conditions d'un
cadre social modernisé un décret socle
qui posera les principales règles
communes pour le secteur ferroviaire
notamment regard des exigences de
sécurité de continuité de service public
le système et la négociation de
convention collective nationale qui
s'appliquera à l'ensemble des opéras des
autres entreprises de la branche
ferroviaire épique mais aussi autres
opérateurs ferroviaires donc et des
négociations d'entreprise là où ce sera
engagée se sont devra être engagé dans
l'ensemble de ces entreprises
avec cette clarification des relations
et des cadres la mise en place des
cadres de dialogue social
nous assurons ce qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui des dispositifs permettant
d'avoir un cadre social commun des
règles sociales communes et surtout
d'avoir la possibilité d'éviter qu'il
n'y ait des distorsions qui soit des
distorsions pour le coût social au
détriment d'opérateurs qui m ont la
charge du service voilà quelques je
pense qu'il faut que je me taise pour
les apps l'assaut des bacs pros vivement
monsieur glissera bien merci merci pour
cette introduction de ce débat donc la
parole est donnée à monsieur michel
teston et à françois patriat s'il peut
rester un petit moment voilà une chaîne
qui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre merci d'avoir présenté de
manière claire les principaux aspects du
projet de loi de réforme ferroviaire
quant à moi fidèle à une tradition que
j'ai mise en place déjà des quelques
auditions sur ce sujet je ne poserai que
quatre questions ce qui permettra aux
autres membres de la commission de
pouvoir s'exprimer largement première
question est le porte sur la nécessité à
mon sens de mettre l'accent sur le
caractère intégré du futur groupe sncf
ce qui suppose l'intégration sociale et
cette question bien évidemment est au
coeur de l'actualité
alors pour moi l'intégration suppose un
d'affirmer la compétence exclusive de
l'epic de tête en matière de gestion
statutaire
c'est un aspect fondamental mais une
bonne intégration sociale
passe aussi par l'affirmation de l'unité
du groupe alors à ce sujet il me semble
que la mise en place d'un comité central
d'entreprise pourrait notamment y
contribuer ce n'est pas le seul aspect
mais je me limiterai a donné cette
indication sur l'état mais réflexion en
la matière alors sans toutefois dévoiler
monsieur michu niveau ne demande pas
surtout pas ce que vous pourrez dire ce
soir et demain aux représentants
syndicaux
pensez vous qu'il soit 7 souhaitable de
renforcer le projet de loi dans ce sens
là c'est important mais sûre pour le
rapporteur que je suis ici au sénat
important de savoir quel est votre avis
sur cette question de l'intégration
sociale deuxième question
elle porte et c'est aussi d'actualité
sur l'inquiétude des cheminots en
matière de maintien de leur statut et de
la future organisation du travail alors
je rappelle qu'il n'a jamais été
question dans ce projet de loi de
remettre en cause le statut des
cheminots
par contre s'agissant de l'organisation
du travail
il ya une large concertation qui est en
cours sous l'autorité de monsieur
baissière et donc il me semble au
porteur là aussi dans le contexte actuel
d'affirmer que l'harmonisation en la
matière ne peut être que par le haut
pouvez vous nous dire quelque chose à ce
stade sur ce sujet parce que c'est un
sujet également important
troisième question elle concerne la
situation financière du système
ferroviaire
on sait très bien qu'on ne peut pas
rester dans la situation actuelle dans
quelle mesure l'état
participera-t-il à cet effort il ya
diverses hypothèses il ya la question de
la dette d'état il ya la question du
dividende
lorsqu'ils existent notamment les
dividendes
lorsqu'il ya un résultat donc la sncf
mobilité et puis il ya effectivement ce
que l'état pourrait également accepté de
ne pas percevoir comme recettes
notamment fiscales
quatrième et dernière question la place
des régions
alors ici le rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des finances est mieux placé
que moi pour évoquer la place des
régions bien qu'il intervienne sinon pas
d'un président de région mais en tant
que rapporteur de la commission des
finances donc je me permettrai malgré
tout françois de dire quelques mots à ce
sujet comment voyez vous monsieur le
ministre leur place dans la nouvelle
organisation tente à ce qui concerne le
transport de voyageurs que le réseau
c'est la question de la représentation
des régions au conseil d'administration
de l'epic de tête mais aussi au ca de
sncf réseau il est pas question qu ils
soient haussées adsl mobilité puisque si
un jour il y avait je ne demande pas à
l'ouverture la concurrence bien
évidemment ce serait impossible pour les
régions d'être dans le ca d'un des
exploitants survient il ya aussi la
question de la propriété des matières
roland c'est une question que pose à
juste titre les régions et puis à la
question de la liberté de tarification
j'arrête là parce que les questions
posées par nos collègues élus régionaux
sont plus nombreuses mais j'ai promis ne
pas être trop long dont je m'arrête là
monsieur le président michel teston
alors monsieur françois patriat puis on
demandera au ministre de vous répondre
mais depuis c'est écouter la réponse
monsieur patrick merci merci monsieur le
président merci de m'avoir invité
d'accueillir comme ce matin à la suite
monsieur le ministre
une réunion qui a été fort intéressante
matin de la part du ce rapport sur la
dette sur les objectifs sur les moyens
sur les sur les difficultés et sur les
priorités qui impose à rff au sont à
poser des choix notamment en matière de
trains grande vitesse par rapport au
musée ce matin avec 300 millions d'euros
par an tout le système secondaire
fonderie qui fonctionnerait bien
j'aimerais bien je n'ai pas repris sur
ce
j'ai après mais j'aimerais bien tant les
sommes qui sont demandées aujourd'hui
collectivité et qui sont engagés par
vous même je l'espère d'ailleurs dans
les futurs contrats de projets dont j'ai
cru comprendre qu'il comportera un volet
mobilité et que la seule priorité serait
le réseau ferroviaire
alors je veux parler si au nom des
régions mais vous dire simplement que si
les régions demain ce sont en
responsabilité pour être celle qui
gérera les stratégies mais aussi les
transports se demandera des moyens comme
le demandent aujourd'hui l'entité sncf
en tout cas de la des transports publics
que nous voulons créer chico la retenue
ce matin d'ailleurs c'était de dire que
rff emprunter 1 million par heure un
million par derrière de 500 millions par
mois et 500 millions à 1 million par
heure donc on voit on voit aujourd'hui
le challenge que vous proposez quand il
faut stabiliser la dette
entendu il sortait nos collègues de ce
matin c'est bon dire que même si la
bonne volonté terrain il n'y croyait pas
et même nous on espère lorsque nous
soutenons ce projet et que nous
souhaitons que demain les erreurs du
passé qui ont fait qu'il ya discuté je
serai quand le président de région
interroge guillaume pepy et qu'il est
dit mais comment se fait-il que la
convention demande comme ça lui même
ce président c'est pas moi c'est les ps
qui augmente et je voulais répercute
comme nous répercutons d'ailleurs y
compris la retraite des agents de la
sncf etc et nous le fait tout le temps
un je répercute qu'on impose la loi
donc on peut pas se renvoyer comme ça
les responsabilités d'où l'intérêt de
niort de ce texte de loi qui va
permettre demain d'avoir une entité
unique où les responsabilités comme les
engagements seront partagés est ce que
nous approuvons totalement
donc si demain doit y avoir des
engagements avec les collectivités
il faudra bien
ministre qu'on soit d'accord sur les
compétences des régions c'est un aparté
mais aussi leurs ressources
parce que demandé aujourd'hui aux
collectivités de payer la voie du wado
de payer la voie ferrée de payer les
routes quand elles sont pas compétentes
alors j'entends bien et de faire marcher
les trains avec 0 0 1 centime de tei
pépé qui n'a rien à voir avec le train
ça peut pas fonctionner comme ça
longtemps donc il faudra six à une
clarification des compétences qui vous
suit leur éducation
c'est un autre sujet mais je sais parce
que j'en ai souvent parlé avec vous que
vous y êtes sensibles bon je vais pas
vous poser beaucoup de questions parce
que je vais devoir partir à la
commission des finances sur le plfr qui
siège à la même mais me résoudre à
interroger aussi les ministres ont
pensez vous qu'on pourra réellement
stabiliser la dette
à quel niveau 1 dans les cinq ans
faut-il que vous avez déjà répondu à la
question faut-il que l'état reprenne une
partie le net parce que on a créé un
outil avec un pays qui est déjà trouvé
du pétrole aujourd'hui un tellement
c'est profond alors on lui avait créé
comme tel vous savez parfois répondu ça
ça ne changera rien à la donne il reste
que rff porte ce poids aujourd'hui c'est
que peut-elle le porter parce que c'est
pas compris dans la dette de l'état y
compris qu'on ne sait pas au total c'est
un métier un non c'est pas compris donc
je vois bien l'intérêt mais est ce qu'on
pourrait faire un peu mieux s'il a
peut-être la seule question pour la vous
avez dit qu'on j'ai compris qu'on devait
gagner un milliard moi j'ai défendu
cette thèse devant les médias début de
semaine 1 500 millions pour l'une et
l'autre des entités
c'est déjà bien vous avez annoncé le
chiffre vous avez 10 91 79 hier ça
paraissait un peu démesuré ce matin aux
auteurs que nous avons rencontrés par
ailleurs mais voilà c'est sur la dette
un peu je voulais vous interrogez en
disant allez pensez vous réellement même
si on économise améliore qu'on pourra
stabiliser la dette dans cinq ans à quel
niveau
et est-ce qu'on pourrait pas sur la
dette future un peu soulagé quand même
pour pouvoir qu'ils soient plus
efficaces demain merci merci je suis
ministre
et vous ces interlocuteurs peut-être
commencer par les préoccupations
régionales régionales je peux dire
régionaliste mais des représentants des
régions sur la place plus précisément
des régions dans le système ferroviaire
c'est vrai qu' il est temps de saisir
l'opportunité de ce projet de loi de
réforme ferroviaire pour donner pleine
mesure à la photographie même de
l'organisation et du financement du
ferroviaire
je comprends même si j'en ai été victime
par le violenter mai mais je comprends
les réactions des présidents de région
se tournant vers le ministre
interpellant président de la sncf
le président de fff en dix ans mais nous
nous participons au financement du
ferroviaire et de quelle manière
tous ceux qui a été l'investissement
majeur des trains régionaux qui ont
amené à des augmentations des lieux de
l'offre est aussi de la demande dans des
conditions tout à fait extraordinaire et
un soutien de la filière ferroviaire
industriels ça n'est pas notre j'étais
ce matin avec un grand groupe industriel
du ferroviaire
ce sont des emplois se sont
des exportations ce sont des innovations
c'est vrai dans l'infrastructure c'est
vrai pour le matériel roulant débat de
d'actualité sur les stratégies c'est
vrai des équipementiers bref nous avons
et ce pour quoi enfin pour un peu d'air
pour en parler pas directement dans le
cadre de plus projet de loi mais la
stratégie de filière ferroviaire que
nous accompagnons avec arnaud montebourg
est une stratégie extrêmement importante
le pouvoir structurer la filière
ferroviaire filière industrielle de la
même façon dans la gouvernance pour y
revenir
la réalité de la participation au
financement et à la définition des
politiques de transport qui sera accrue
d'un projet de décentralisation qui vous
est soumis amène ce que à la fois dans
mais je réponds en même temps michel
teston à la fois dans le
conseil de surveillance du les pics de
tête donc dans la structure de tête il y
aura des sièges de sièges réservés aux
régions et ce sera également le cas dans
le conseil d'administration de l'epic
sncf raison initialement dans les pics
de tête ça n'était pas prévu
d'abord parce que il faut bien faire
attention à ce que ça ne touche pas des
questions liées à cette série mobilité
le jour venu
aujourd'hui cette la présence allait
légitime et nous appartiendront nous
appartiendra d'organiser le moment venu
participation sans qu'il n'y ait
d'interférence avec les enjeux des snf
mobilité nous avons également nos
étudiants mais enfin nous étudions
favorablement
ça vous permet d'avoir un état d'esprit
les demandes qui sont des demandes
émanant de les régions concernant l'âme
est la propriété du matériel roulant
cette discussion que nous avons eue en
commission à l'assemblée nationale que
ne manqueront pas d'avoir ici le banc
aujourd'hui je le disais aux collègues
de l'assemblée la propriété du matériel
roulant
elle était elle est consultante bien de
retour encore faut-il que ce ne soit pas
une forme d' anticipation à la
libéralisation parce que ça n'a de sens
que s'il s'agit de remettre à
disposition en fin de contrat
des du matériel roulant à disposition
d'autres opérateurs et ne sommes pas
dans ce cadre là pour autant c'est vrai
les régions financent par le biais de la
sncf
alors peut-être va pas intermédiaire xss
il ya certainement une là une évolution
à apporter parce qu'il est légitime que
lorsqu'on achète quelque chose se soit
pas celui qui l'achète en votre nom
si l'on soit propriétaire c'est une
forme de voile c'est vrai aussi la
propriété des biens immobiliers mais de
ce point de vue nous avons encore à
progresser sur ces questions et de la
liberté tarifaire
je sais que c'est une revendication
j'amène et c'est mon rôle
quelques bémols cette liberté tarifaire
elle doit malgré tout garantir
l'existence de tarification sociale
khider tête de tarification sociale
nationale donc sous réserve
en tout cas cette aujourd'hui l'état du
texte après un désaccord courtois mais
des accords malgré tout qui aboutit à
forme
de consensus de négociation d'un texte
reconnaissant ou tendant vers la
reconnaissance anne liberté tarifaire se
réserve de dumas tiers des tarifs
sociaux et un certain nombre de taxes ce
prise en compte par l'état au nom de la
région mais tout cela aura la taxe doit
revendre d'accès je sais que ça fait
débat
lorsque l'on parle argent ça fait
toujours débat et lorsque l'on veut
plein de compétences il faut que l'on
ait plein clarification de qui paie quoi
au nom de qui et pour faire quoi
voilà donc les avancées sur cette
question pour ceux qui y est de l'
équilibre financier mais veut peut-être
voyez sur l'équilibré financier
le constat c'est de toute façon les
chiffres sont capables c'est vrai qu'ils
sont éloquents n'avait pas en tête celui
d'un million par par jour par heure 500
millions déjà par jour 500 millions par
an c'est dire il faut qu'on aille vite
c'est pour ça peut-être que le texte a
été déclarée en urgence et que nous
arrivions vite un texte voté conforme
elle a commencé ça fait depuis ce matin
ah oui beaucoup des chèvres 6e
ferroviaire vous anticipez vous gagnez
du temps
esker 8h ce qu'il ya des matchs
rétroactive un stop stop the clocks donc
une dette qui progresse annuellement
alors selon que l'on intègre ou non les
lignes lgv sans esprit de polémique mais
en réalité tout de même puisque c'est
une réalité que l'on doit assumer les
lignes lgv qui ont été engagées
concomitamment 4 alors même que la
soutenabilité financière était d'une
ligne lgv tous les 5 6 ans quatre lignes
lgv
lens est quasiment dans la même période
viens nous laisses tes le ferroviaire
façon insurmontable alors tant mieux
pour ceux qui sont bénéficiaires de la
grande vitesse encore faut-il qu'elles
aient un sens mais ça c'est un autre
débat et c'est un débat de la stratégie
ferroviaire que le parlement devrait
avoir
actuellement il n'y a pas ce lieu de
débat et 7
ce rendez-vous nécessaire donc il y à
des projections après échanges avec la
sncf avec rff l'état oui cher monsieur
le rapporteur viendra porter sa
contribution notamment par leur
versement des dividendes
vers le gestionnaire unique
d'infrastructures donc abandonnera ses
dividendes
c'est quand même 500 millions et
permettra donc la consolidation au
niveau du groupe des déficits fiscaux et
cette consolidation sera intégré dans le
prochain collectif budgétaire bien les
gains de production à meilleure
organisation la politique d'achat les
fonctions support devrait permettre à la
sncf mobilité d'organiser un plan qui
sera un plan touchant jusqu'à gain d'un
milliard nous soutient la sncf
je retiens le chu est pour sa part et 7
cf réseau évoqua propre performance de
synergies de l'ordre de 900 millions
alors c'est vrai que ce sont des enjeux
difficile à atteindre
il faut que l'on puisse s'en portaient
tous garant pour ça d'ailleurs que je
fais d'autant plus à l'aise que cette
invitation que il est important je
réponds ans la transition
des questions de michel teston un cadre
social discussions les organisations
syndicales savent très bien
l'état du ferroviaire et au delà de
cette période qui serait deux périodes
un peu agité la discussion c'est normal
chacun saisi du débat mais je crois
vraiment qu elles savent là où il ya des
gains de d'efficacité de productivité de
politique commerciale savent très bien
sur le fret ce qui peut être mieux
organisé d'ailleurs à participer au
groupe de travail que je lançais les
organisations syndicales représentant
des salariés sont souvent avec des
propositions qui elles mêmes peuvent
être génératrice de meilleurs résultats
économiques du groupe
non je suis pas pour une culture
d'affrontements fait pour une culture de
partage d'objectifs cet objectif là
j'aimerais qu'il soit partagé par tous
et que soient pas monsieur preppy
monsieur rapoport monsieur cuvillier qui
viennent vous livrer ses chiffres
moi parce que me les a donnés eux parce
qu'ils les ont calculé mais que ce soit
à partir de ces chiffres une oeuvre
collective permettant de sauver le
ferroviaire
donc dans ce cadre là il est souhaitable
que nous puissions avoir des lieux
peut-être même un suivi nous verrons
avec les organisations syndicales
comment elle aborde la suite de cette
réforme pour assurer l'effectivité dans
la difficulté est grande
j'ai été à couper sur la dette mais
avant de revenir sur les questions
syndicales
c'est vrai que toute la dette sera pas
diminué par une stabilisation par nature
mais d'ores et déjà si nous ne réglons
pas ce problème de l'accroissement de la
dette fasse savoir que et du traitement
de la dette qui doit être gelée dit dans
mon propos liminaire par étapes
traitement de la dette après
stabilisation y compris organisationnel
effectivité de l'efficacité de
l'organisation
c'est le contribuable qui sera appelée
elle ne fait on pas que contribuable
soit appeler cela mais pour autant de
l'ordre de 10 milliards de dette
jade être ma part on réduit de
maastricht visé en tout cas bref
et comment voilà des milliards de
milliards de dette de rff
sur les 37 qui sont considérés comme
d'être qualifié de dette dette
maastricht yens et donc qui amènera à ce
que l'effort collectif de la nation et
c'est le bien de la nation je n'avais
pas de dire c'est vrai c'est le bien de
la nation celui bien de chacun d'entre
nous c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs y compris
dans le débat parlementaire et pourra y
avoir des évolutions sur la garantie du
patrimoine national ferroviaire
peut-être alors je dis ça généralement
ils sont mon cabinet takeo la dir dgitm
sont toujours inquiets que lorsque je
fais des auditions par ce que dit des
choses comme ça et ça disent oui mais il
faut qu'on a eu peut-être plus de loi si
nous pouvons aller plus loin sur ces
questions de reconnaissance du
patrimoine de la nation de
l'appartenance du ferroviaire pour
patrimoine de la nation c'est
indispensable et ce sera peut-être une
demande des syndicats ce sera là une
demande lorsqu'elle fort courant
un os de l'organiser avec vous voilà
alors sur les questions plus sociale
l'organisation
d'abord je j'écouterai ce que diront les
organisations syndicales ce soir et
demain je regarderai dans quelle mesure
il peut le refaire leur être apportée
réponse c'est vrai que ce n'est pas
simple mais je comprends aussi que la
tante d'une garantie d'intégration passe
aussi par le niveau le plus élevé de la
reconnaissance sociale
mais lesquels amène aussi parfois des
dérogations des règles qui sont
actuellement applicables en matière de
représentation des salariés donc faisons
le point
mais nous anticipons et nous avons
anticipé pour essayer d'apporter en tout
cas des orientations à des réponses sont
pas des rencontres boulevard
saint-germain qui se substituent aux
travaux parlementaires non plus donc il
faut que chacun ait bien conscience de
son rôle mais c'est un point qui n'est
pas fermé et qui doit nous permettre
d'avoir des lieux de notamment comité
central d'entreprise
regardez puis les lieux de négociation
collective
quant au statut de statut nous l'avait
indiqué je les ai rappelés n'est pas
mise en cause du tout voilà ce que je
peux apporter
j'étais suffisamment précis réponse
merci je suis ministre
à ce niveau de discussion puisque vous
avez vous-même que nous étions entre
nous mais quand on voit la difficulté
avec laquelle on traite ce problème de
la dette est ce qu'on peut vous poser la
question de savoir où en est on de cette
écotaxe c'est qu'elle me
il ya quand même un peu d'argent là qui
devrait être au rendez vous et
deuxièmement comment vous avez parlé de
patrimoine patrimoine mais comment at on
pu brader le patrimoine autoroutier qui
aujourd'hui un bénéfice de 2 milliards
est ce que les organismes qui ont acheté
les banques et cetera ne pourrait pas
faire un effort ne peut-on pas faire de
ce problème là un problème où tout le
monde apporterait sa contribution parce
que à coût de 500 millions par cissé 5
millions par là entre nous soit dit bon
puisqu'on entre nous ça va durer un
certain temps et à raison de 500
millions par mois
c'est quand même est friand donc moi je
vous le dis très sincèrement c'est pas
mon habitude je n'interviens pas quand
mes collègues interviennent mais ces
deux milliards attendus donc de
l'écotaxe va bien falloir que ya une
décision qui sera prise en ce qui
concerne le sénat il ya eu une
discussion passionnée et féroce mais on
a trouvé un consensus pour dire on
n'arrêtera pas à travers une enquête
la mise en oeuvre possible de l'écotaxe
dont le sénat s'est prononcé dans des
difficultés et qu'on avait rarement
connu mais finalement a pris ses
responsabilités en disant voilà il faut
donner la possibilité à l'état
d'appliquer cette écotaxe on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on a absolument besoin
je vais répondre tout de suite parce que
c'était un sujet qui est attendu non pas
venons pas inattendu du tout parce que
c'est vrai que dans le contrat de plan
d'ailleurs attendu sur ce cette
question-là contrat de plan état région
il ya des financements qui viennent
évidemment des recettes attendues de
l'écotaxe il y a eu le débat les
lointains le consensus
il est encore plus lointain et puis il y
a eu la responsabilité et le sens des
responsabilités qui est de moins en
moins partagée sous prétexte qu'il ya
une évolution wild et moins en moins de
partager parce que je vois que des
parlementaires qui ont une conception
qui n'est pas une conception prenant
toute la mesure de l'intérêt général de
solidarité oui mais et qui dans le même
temps à demander le comprends mais
demande le financement d'infrastructures
mois ce qui m'obsède sait comment
finance-t-on des infrastructures c'est
mon obsession c'est une obsession n'est
pas d'avoir une écotaxe pour l'éco taxe
en obsession n'est pas d'avoir honoré
absolument un contrat ecomouv encore que
tant que ministre de la république la
signature et la parole de l'état doit
amener à une forme de continuité mais
s'il y a négocié renégocier nous
l'avions engagée avant le remaniement ne
le poursuivant bien évidemment